A rare sight in St Peter's Square.
This is part of the Vatican City's new athletics
team...and they are ready to take on the world.
The Vatican may be the smallest state on earth
but the team has lofty ambitions.
With regards to the Olympics, the dream we
have is to be carrying the vatican flag during
the opening ceremony of a Games.
A marathon-running priest and a half marathon-loving
nun are among the team members.
For me, when I began running, it gave me the
chance to rediscover inner peace, to find
a balance, to have time for silence.
The Vatican competing at the Olympics may
still be a way off.
But a leap of faith is all they need.